es cierto buenas tardes primero buenos
días de hecho estamos entrando en la
época del invierno que significa que
primero pasamos más tiempo adentro y no
tanto tiempo afuera como anteriormente
durante verano y así aumenta la duración
de la exposición y además usamos
calefacción porque hace falta y la
calefacción el aire calefacción que
perjudica la glucosa y la hace más
susceptible a toda clase de gérmenes
incluidos los virus y se sabe que la
época de los resfríos por otra parte un
factor importante que además porque es
el segundo invierno en que entramos es
que la gente empieza a perder la
conciencia en muchos casos por parte
porque están acumulados en siguientes
seguros y tomaron menos en serio las
medidas de precaución precoz por de
acción que todavía se justifican sobre
todo durante la etapa de enviado
avanzamos mucho tiempo adentro
bueno y entretanto varios países se
apuran para ordenar dosis de refuerzo
para sus ciudadanos el último ejemplo es
francia que este martes hizo el anuncio
para los mayores de 50 años y le
preguntó hará la diferencia tener una
inyección más o el problema son los
opositores al medicamento que no han
obtenido su esquema completo de
inmunización
y hombre ve ganamos un poco tiempo con
la tercera dosis así que hay que ver que
en los países donde se aplican
obviamente israel el país más avanzado
en ese contexto se gana un poco el
tiempo en la medida en que la gente más
vulnerable
sigue siendo menos susceptible al virus
al hobbit 19 por un tiempito pero el
problema persiste el problema grave es
la duración
relativamente corto corta de la de la
vacuna y
que pierde efectividad después del vídeo
años más o menos después de un par de
meses así que si se justifica arriba a
las personas sobre todas las personas
vulnerables pero hay que ver hay que
tener en cuenta de que solamente ganamos
unos seis meses y después que vamos a
pasar claro aquí estaremos en un lp
verano y con menor riesgo pero así se
justifica por el momento pero no ayuda
para superar la pandemia una vez por
todas
y ya para finalizar está bola será
diferente de las anteriores en europa
difícil pregunta no sé decir parece que
no yo no les quiero mucha diferencia
aquí en europa el central y norte del
norte hay más personas vacunadas que
están parcialmente protegidas frente a
dar al virus y por por lo menos por lo
tanto menos asequibles así que puede que
sea menor pero hay que saber al mismo
tiempo que un 30 por ciento de los
pacientes ingresados en cuidados
intensivos en alemania son personas
vacunadas así que la transición a través
de la vacuna es relativa así que no es
quiero diferencias tan fundamentales
frente a las olas anteriores